[Music]
for me chad thinks himself a cross
between prince and rick james in his
swagger which he really doesn't have
that much of
[Music]
i was honored to play
nathan because my brother
struggles through mental health
disorders specifically bipolar disorder
and so i already had a huge appreciation
for
the journey
and
the difficulties and and also
the high moments the beautiful moments
right of that navigation playing candola
in her postpartum stage as i was in my
own postpartum stage it really informed
my own like how i think about my family
and the kind of sacrifices you make for
your kids and
it's beautiful but it's also taxing and
exhausting and she's tired and i was
tired i thought we were really soul
sisters
in season one i just come from another
show where i was like a 215 pound
football player so i i was told to stop
working out and stop cutting my hair and
stop shaving but i think yeah i mean you
know from a character perspective there
is a big transformation from how he
you know stopped getting haircut stop
shaving probably wasn't working out and
then season two he runs a marathon um he
leveled up and like every time he
leveled up he dressed a little nicer and
his watch got a little nicer and the job
in the office and the house and the
apartment like all those things got a
little bit better and i think season one
he was very much like shoulders rolled
over kind of a dude who was uh had low
self-esteem i think by the time you get
to season five he's earned like
you know the open chest kind of like
this is who i am and i'm very
comfortable with that to play a
character that loves herself
unconditionally
challenged the level to which i accepted
myself and i've been changed by her i
think that's why i love putting the
character of kelly on so much and to
have her do that for others come on it
doesn't get better than that it does not
get better than that
[Music]
you